what i did was uh i went to this book
and i said okay what do these words mean
let's let's look him up
and the first thing i do uh in his case
is i look up
the word count because then you can get
a ballpark figure
of what his favorite words are how he's
going to use him okay and here's his uh
famous uh word count okay
mass that word belongs to the
establishment it's a it's a
private property of the establishment so
no dissident talks too much about mass
they would rather talk about all these
other concepts and
uh energy because it's another form of
mass uh he doesn't
emphasize that too much he does talk a
little bit about inertia
but as you can see by the number he uses
an income measurable vortex and
conjugate he uses these fancy words that
have no meaning and they're not defined
in his book uh but uh you can see at the
bottom dielectric and derivatives you
know dielectricity and so on
oh he loves that word he's got it 1600
times in there
field he's got half of that and then
ether he's got 380 and counter spatial
313.
but it turns out counter spatial and
ether in his language are
synonyms okay so he's got 700 there and
it turns out that ether counter space
spatial and dielectric are synonyms
in his language so he's got a total of
1600 plus 700 he's got a total of 2 400
versions of dielectric ether and counter
spatial against
about 800 fields so he's got three times
as many uh
instances of dielectric ether encounter
spatial as he does a field
so you can see how he's gonna drive his
his theory
and those are the words you have to look
up so the word i look up first
is this word counter spatial okay
and as you can see here um you know he
says
the ether uh cannot be in space he says
space is within the ether he goes
through here he never defines it and by
the time i got to page 54 i finally gave
up
uh but it's important to see what he's
saying there counter space is literally
the space between space itself and that
contrasts against what he said at the
beginning
and so i said well let's see let's see
if i can illustrate what uh good old ken
wheeler is saying maybe we can get to
the bottom of this and so i decided to
illustrate it and here's the
illustration
okay he says the ether is counter space
and cannot be in space rather space is
within the ether that's on page 29
that's
uh illustration number one you can see
space is in or within
or whatever the ether great whatever the
ether is okay now he says next he says
counter space is literally the space
between
space itself that's number two now ether
is between the two spaces
it's no longer that the space is
included within the ether
now the next one he says number three
which uh says the ether right
which requires conjugate field forces to
bring it into
space now either is in or within or
into space so you can see that through
the
pages he goes into this contradiction he
doesn't have a
slightest clue what he's saying okay so
i looked up the other word this uh the
word dielectric i'm saying what is this
and so i go there and they have he has
all these dielectric uh
instances one of the again the most
popular were probably in his
book and i finally got to page 18 and
finally found some
measure of an idea of what dielectric or
dielectricity means
he says is the ether under stress or
strained in other words he's saying it's
the ether under motion of some kind
that's what he's saying that's a dynamic
concept what is
uh what is he talking about well he's
talking about a jumping kangaroo which i
touched upon in previous uh videos a
jumping kangaroo is not
a physical object a kangaroo is an
object and this guy does
his physics with jumping kangaroos
that's the issue he's saying
dielectricity is a jumping kangaroo
you got to get to the bottom of the
ether obviously he wants you need to
know what
the ether since everything is synonymous
with ether you want to know what the
ether is okay what is the ether
so i go in there and look up you know
what the ether is
an ether is a medium he's got that all
over his book and that's a mediator
that's a medium
okay he's got it everywhere and so it's
some kind of medium in fact in the
previous one he said it's got a membrane
so i guess that's a
medium so we need to know what a medium
is well of course guru can doesn't
define what a medium is
the ether is also made of particles
he says cathode ray is not election but
actually corpuscles of the ether
and he talks about the gaseous ether is
the seed of electrical
phenomena okay so when you get an idea
you say okay obviously the ether is made
of particles
uh is the ether finite or infinite well
it's both in his theory
there is nothing outside the ether
that's on page 28
you would think if there's nothing
outside the ether it would look like
that
first picture like the infinite ether
otherwise you would have something
surrounding the ether it would be
thought the fourth dimension or whatever
i don't care what you surround it with
but it would be surrounded by some black
stuff in this case you want to make it
red make it red fine
but the issue is that either the ether
is infinite or it's finite
and then he's got there the ether is
brought into space you see the ether is
enclosed within space
and in number three it's against space
so it's a
you know hitting against it it's surface
to surface so you can see again the
inconsistency we have no idea whether
the ether is finite or
infinite not from objectively looking at
his uh
book it turns out the ether also has
physical properties okay and here it is
says ether has pressure you know it's
compressibility of the ether
uh ether can be polarized it has stress
and strain
and it can decelerate and i assume
somewhere i'm going to find that the
ether also
accelerates so he's got all these uh
what is it physical properties of the
ether
i got to distinguish these guys and
that's why i attack them i attack them
because
science is not criticism but i need to
criticize these guys so that you can see
a contrast
otherwise people say well bill's just
another dissident he does the same thing
as all these other guys
and a lot of people say why don't you
join the electric universe why don't you
join you know these
these dissidents and no these people are
my biggest enemies because
they are misleading intellectuals
intelligent laymen who railed against
the establishment